So, while adding these two buttons, some students had trouble while playing and
stopping audio.
I want to address those concerns in this video.
Now, here in my Play Sounds View Controller, I have actions for
play slow audio, play fast audio, and stop audio.
I'm going to run this project and see if it works.
Here, I will play the move quote slowly, and then fast, and
then I will stop all audio.
Take a listen [SOUND].
Now you may have noticed that when I press any one of these two buttons while
the audio is already playing, the playback starts not from the beginning but
from when I actually pressed any one of these two buttons.
You can keep that functionality, if you'd like.
Although, if you want to start the audio from the beginning.
You can use this property called currentTime and set it to 0.0.
Let me do that in both slow and fast.
Okay, let me run this project one more time.
Now, this time the audio will start from the beginning.
>> My mom always said.
My momma always said, life was like a box of chocolates.
>> Cool.
Now one final thing to notice here is that the code for
both the slow and the fast actions is looking really similar to each other.
Here is an opportunity for you to put the common code in a new function.
And then call that new function from both the Play Slow Audio and
the Play Fast Audio actions.
All right, if you have any more questions about how to make these two
buttons work, ask those questions in the discussion forum, we are here to help